dopo st partenza non possiamo giocare
che ne so solitario e proprio atto
fiorito ragazzi tutti ragazzi benvenuti
questo video sono vari j
oggi siamo su file nei set candy
federtennis
2 perché hanno fatto anche lui non ci
sta non avevo dubbi guarda new game
ehi ciao fratello aiuta ci sono quasi un
quarto c'è anche un bel cappello
lol hai perso la scommessa ma guarda e
scommesse zio giochiamo a poker
lo sai che cosa vuol dire cosa vuol dire
devi passare cinque notti nella vecchia
fattoria di nuovo nella vecchia fattoria
cefali j
tutti quanti sono contenti pure mi
chiede se ho paura no a fare già i never
heard
skerry to speaking nine a fuck you your
mama e janis il mouse assori di checa
che inserite questa questo è scemo prova
seriamente fra quel senso di sta roba
la prima volta che posso scrivere
veramente in un horror qual era il senso
se circondato dall oscuri ma qua siamo
nella vecchia fattoria iaia circondato
dall oscurità premi spazio per
utilizzare flash della camera per dal
tuo cellulare
bello usa questo per riuscire appena
vedere nello schema è tanto non vedo una
massa uguale click di mouse da wars 2 ok
nel prevedere la telecamera solita roba
che figo ciao ragazzi ho fatto molto
meglio di farine del freddo poi che ci
sono i telefoni a perché posso chiamare
che figo che posso chiamare le varie
stanze tv così mi squilla the air è che
figata
bordello non ho capito un cazzo però mio
spuntato sto tizio che non è bellissimo
bene non ho capito un cazzo però ve devo
usare i telefoni apparentemente per
mandare via asti deficienti quando cioè
quando mi compaiono qua devo usare i
telefoni credo per mandarli via
salve connection loss a merda merda
chiama chiama chiama chiama c'è la nonna
al telefono ti sta chiamando perfetto
funzionano lega sanzionato scemo io
salve ma il telefono era qua comunque
non li che cosa ci si capisce solo
questa qui è domandato mandato porca
merda vai vai vai mai mai mai mai
ok no non se n'è andato non esiste che
quando la nonna chiama al telefono ci
sta ai 5 minuti non esiste io quando mi
chiamava mia nonna stava tutta vita cioè
proprio devo aspettare di morire io la
prima nostra il genere ce la faccio
sempre in qualsiasi gioco di phinet
freddy's quello che sono le altre notti
il problema come tutti ragazzi che
riesco a perdere prima che scattino le 6
no perché io sosta sfiga e non so se
qualcuno già presente ce la fa qualcuno
da quante ore sono le 5 del mattino
porca eva dai gas e 6 no no niente non
scattano le sei niente rimarremo a vita
alle 5 del mattino va bene fantasia 6
del mattino ragazzo è stato orribile sul
gioco ganassin che dire
e c'era solo uno o aspettare devo tipo
insultarti in chat come prima questa
roba
sono condotti con chi ha tanto c'è una
porta kill ecco è uguale a find and the
fray di sarah che sembra che abbia gli
occhiali quelli da qui xscope
ecco la chiave
grazie adesso devo tornare indietro
possono gare su facebook
quanto è strano che non è spuntato
nessuno cioè se è stranissimo
spero stai calmo devi stare più calmo
abita cos'è successo
fai letters kelis 2 continuo qualcuno mi
spiega che cosa ha appena fatto perché
non ho capito un pene cycle night mi
fece notare con tizio di prima anche
dove insultarli la madre per cortesia se
hai voglia e poi non lo so bene
ho sempre a niente non mi fa insultare
il tizio ragazzi quindi siamo partiti
realtà 20 senza tizio dovrei in teoria
adesso avere il nuovo nemico
credo poi non lo so salve a velo in figo
c'è sempre uno degli animatronics non ho
letto ma perché non riesco a leggere
tenterà di uccidersi attraverso il
sistema di ventilazione se senti il
rumore arrivare dalle ventole trova la
camera dell'anima tronic is his own the
cold cellphone due corni chi cazzo è
questo frate non hai capito
devi devo a ad o chiamare ho capito
quando io vedo uno che mi smonta al
sistema di ventilazione devo chiamare
così risponde al telefono e si dimentica
che sta svitando le pale qual è il senso
visto gioco si capisce un cazzo
dov'è il tipo dove donkey kong scusate
che c'era il tipo che tentava di smith
eccolo eccolo ora ti chiama mia zia al
telefono ecco vedi che se ne va come si
caga addosso quando squilla il telefono
e poi arriva l'altra pp qual è il senso
di stallo ragazzi devo solo spostarlo
quando mi smonta la ventola tratto st
porta mezza aperta non mi piace un cazzo
oh merda merda merda chiama ho letto era
del iii n il cane ama self risponde al
telefono strano stato questa la ciabatta
più brutta che abbia mai visto in tutta
la mia vita non sa della bella lascia
proprio una bella ciabatta altro che de
fonseca sto scherzando e si tour infatti
la gamba 6 tempo una ceretta
ma non hanno che sta smontando lui sta
smontando bastardo ma fatemi capire se
smonterà la roba ciò nel culo c'è nel
senso morto tra un po anima trony
desidera un animatronics di compagnia
non è di mediashopping animatronica
acquista anche tu un compagno di
compagni
pulisce la casa chi smonta le ventole
non seriamente ragazzi quanti
animatronics ci vogliono evitare un
cazzo di condotta da me non hanno voglio
saperlo sentite senti tu e le connection
lost non mi funziona il computer anno
quello sta svuotando o cristo o cristo
non lo chiama chiama chiama chiama alza
la cornetta mondial babic aspetta
condotto di ventilazione lo smalto anche
bello no perché anche se me lo spiego il
mio cervello quando deve fare due cose
non riesce cioè nel senso o guarda una
cosa non mi guardo un altro anche quando
giro che cammino per strada non è che
posso scrivere i messaggi sul telefono
perché allo stesso tempo devo camminare
quindi o scrivo o inciampo amy sfracello
sull'asfalto una delle due cioè io
chiamo mia madre dico di giocare insieme
a me al suo gioco lei controlla quello
delle ventole io controllo tizio o
notizia non capita è una donna al
davanzale posso farvi una domanda ma non
hai e la curiosità è una curiosità mia
perché sto cristiano qui devi andare
nelle faq delle fabbriche per una
scommessa e ci sono degli animatronica
c'è ma sei scemo no frate non frate il
brutto è che se parlo non sento tizio
che smonta l'evento era una scommessa
sto deficiente è andato in una fabbrica
e in questa fabbrica ci sono sti cosi e
proprio da da difficile ma proprio te
devi impegnare
poi tra l'altro non va c'è io faccio
squillare il telefono ma lui non va al
telefono lui va da un'altra parte
notate la sta cosa è se lui sta
smontando chiamo ed esce e poi arriva la
tipa che squilla il telefono ma rimane
così ciò che voi sapete come funziona un
telefono non lo chiedo è che non ha
secondo me non sa pertanto nei pacchi
qualcuno mi invii questo questo cioè se
qualcuno riesce a fare i pupazzi me lo
fate questo caso qui ti prego che
bellissimo bene roba visto che così
spesso i telefoni chiama un dentista
fissano un appuntamento che non è che fa
male dai dai dai dai che sono arrivati
alla fine dai cultura 65
pensavo di essere morto va bene così ma
è adesso mi devi far fare il nuovo e
cosa
pinguino cioè questo qua sarebbe il mio
prossimo nemico
qualcuno ha spiegato per terra è una
merda non l'ha veramente fatto vero non
è moda questa c'è bisogno di ognuno si
veste come vuole ok ho raccolto tutto
sono bravo raccogli kakà il mento qua
perfetto che belgio vita raccogli merda
simulator sia meraviglioso terza notte
ragazzi vi sia fantastico mi sono
sbloccato un nuovo nemico inquino
raccogli feci
non vedo l'ora di vederlo ragazzo fatti
vedere mostrati a mente accordo ragazzi
concludo che l'episodio continuerò nel
prossimo spero che mi sia piaciuto un
bel mi piace per le merde che ho
raccolto perché migliaia le meritano un
bel live anche afasia di facebook e come
nei video tratta descrizione solo se il
city sky ci vediamo in questo video e
ragazzi